this is France returning to action today
the nation's stations were open again
masks on our mandatory here and familiar
across Europe French travelers are
exempt from Britain's quarantine plans
the lockdown has been eased but not
removed still for some a metro journey
felt like a big step forward
a pitcher dock
in Belgium shops reopened in the
sunshine people queuing patiently to get
in this country has been very badly hit
by the virus today you could sense the
desire to get back to normal things as
soon as more common with Zika to Mokey's
he want he knows that he'd know on
Fatima normal pathway the truth at the
magazine I love Leo etc don't we soon as
more migraine effect is on TV I'm below
the most way over system or adulty long
fearless of teeter-totter long magazine
affair even waipahu the keel here in
Brussels there was a one-way system for
shoppers those curves on the floor mark
out the mandatory distance gap but as we
watched the guidelines were often
ignored the lesson here is that shopping
doesn't really mix world with strict
social distancing this might look like
an everyday visit to the shops but don't
be tricked by the illusion because there
are limits on how many people can go
into each store how long they can remain
there how they can pay for their
purchases and bits of these shops have
been closed off so the question isn't
whether or not this is a return to
normality it's more about how long are
we going to have to live like this there
is nervousness to some bus and tram
drivers were on strike today fearful
that lockdown restrictions have been
lifted too quickly
elsewhere relief this is severe in Spain
where bars and cafes are slowly opening
businesses in desperate need of money
now hoping for customers the players of
real madrid back in training hoping that
their league will restart in june but
there is one trade now facing an influx
of clients hairdressers have returned in
the netherlands and beyond a lot of us
seem desperate to say goodbye to our
unruly lockdown locks
Adam Parsons Sky News Brussels